oh hello oh there's no one driving that
[ __ ]
mm-hmm oh cool
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to hello neighbor now
we still have our creep of a neighbor as
you saw in that intro movie but this
game has been updated and even the
developer said that the old version of
the game was like a year old so this one
is way more recent and offers a lot more
in terms of actual legitimate gameplay
and maybe have a little bit of story but
also wiser oh it wasn't giant I was just
next to it hi hidey-ho neighbor II know
you're looking good there with all your
boarded up windows and all your how did
you put it
upper deck that high I used to build
decks for a living that just doesn't
seem practical so what was that oh I saw
that the [ __ ] was that was that like a
train car do you ever roller coaster in
your house so anyway we gotta be Jex's
now we need to turn on the electricity
check inside move stuff inside and then
take a nap which is exactly what I want
to do with my life except I don't take
naps you know what before I do anything
I'm gonna go say hi to the neighbor oh I
was not wrong what the [ __ ] is that and
also how do I build one of those in my
house it seems awesome
oh hi hello what are you doing in your
bathroom why are you locked inside your
own bathroom buddy what are you doing
there
you havin a good time you need any help
alright you take care neighbor I'll see
you around maybe then rescued activate
okay how does he uh husky there we go
hi okay mmm press f to pick up okay cool
left mouse button to use item cool oh
yes but bear okay that key will be
secured right there no one's gonna break
in I'm almost assured of that can I go
too hey why why am i under the bed
this doesn't seem like a thing that
should happen okey-dokey then
oh I need to move stuff in don't I can
have my stuff please pretty please
oh oh I'm strong as hell okay um right
here is good huh blood okay chair you
handle all that material over there I'll
bring the rest of this [ __ ] in over here
okay I that's good I guess three okay
good enough yay
I'm not even gonna close my front door
I'm not even gonna close this door or
shut the blinds humming she's gonna go
to sleep
ah what did I sleep am I am i certain
that I slept alrighty then
oh that was a good sleep neighbor did
you sleep well Oh neighbor hi do you
want to be fat what happened to all your
boarded up windows that was the weird
whoa
uh-huh all the familiar sounds what is
that I got a hat no one will ever notice
me with my hat apparently hello wait
wheeler room all righty then neighbor
I've just popped by for a visit
hello oh it's the bathroom that he likes
so much neighbor neighbor rarity then I
found your hat neighbor oh hey
oh [ __ ] good god oh [ __ ] that [ __ ] okay
no one told me that I was gonna be a
part of this Oh
neighbor neighbor okay neighbor ever
done won't play by never ah okay
okay I'm going upstairs you can't stand
on me whoa hey what the [ __ ] where there
Shark Boy okay hi yo again with the
weird I don't know what that is I don't
know why that is what the [ __ ] oh it's a
portal to another dimension okay you
just freeze there all I'm not paying
attention at all okay well that was
bizarre the neighbor seems to be a bit
of a son of a [ __ ] his house seems to
be a endless loop of nightmares so let's
go in it Barton right in I'm not gonna
jump into your goddamn shark pit like
holy [ __ ] II oh geez oh it wants me real
bad
can I throw this bing-bong uh don't mind
me here ah god damn it
all right fine then right so if I take
this box up with me I should be able to
hip-hop ooh hello
yeah okay hey ah hello oh my me yeah
okay hey okay so I just got a Hibou
don't knock my box I can't really get it
running huh ah come on I'm gonna take
both these boxes that's got Hal Bay a
trash can on a dollar so I can [ __ ] my
my legs are stuck in your goddamn bull's
head oh hi huh
oh I'm still stuck I can't move
oh I never hi
okay weird why did I get kerb uncle
Dover there
I okay hi he went the wrong way like an
idiot okay so if I go over here why the
[ __ ] is this huh Hey Oh God hi fast [ __ ]
Oh what the [ __ ] is this
I must be this old hide with the sack
what is this [ __ ] hello okay alright
okay uh ah okay is it like a tutorial
it's it's a circle isn't it it's a
tutorial it's a horrifying tutorial in
this set of a theme park I had I had
effectively okay that didn't make any
second head to him sense at all the [ __ ]
is up with this place here it's got an
instruction thing wait a minute
I need the Bell oh that's why I needed
to go up there I need to bail ah suck
her up okay got the Bell okay so I just
got to get back so now oh come I'm not
know it no doodad
oh whoa come on I just got a hope he's
not downstairs he's not okay
god damn it that's not correct what did
that do oh I can use objects - oh that's
good to know
oh god don't do that don't do that don't
do that hey my chair you sack of [ __ ]
her oh [ __ ] off
[ __ ] you get out of the way oh come on
ah [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] guys put a trash
can on my head and try to hide
okay don't knock my goddamn trash cans
please yeah ah ah yes yes yes I know
okay got it
don't don't Scott dude come on you
[ __ ]
ah get it get it get it get it come on
Jesus Christ no god damn it [ __ ] [ __ ]
you seriously just [ __ ] off oh [ __ ] you
what's getting the [ __ ] damn what oh
really
god oh it let me get stuck in it it
struck me in it are you kidding me well
alright that's that's enough
cuz this these are all options for
things you could do or you could [ __ ]
behave yourself
and okay just let let me oh yes yes I'm
Audi I'm out the front door I'm gonna go
around the goddamn back with my goddamn
Bell and [ __ ] you
now what the hell well that doesn't seem
natural was has that always been there
[ __ ] hello hi how are you why are you
up there
what are you doing is that another
version of you how did you get there are
you enjoying your calisthenics I think
oh [ __ ] okay he's gone that's weird
okay yeah yeah okay hmm what is that
what is that what is that what am I
looking at
oh hi what was due I didn't want this
was this really old it where's why
there's so many men
chickens that's a big concern of mine
and why is this one here do I need to
bring this back to my house oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh sorry I didn't mean to take your
grandma huh take this open this up maybe
I get up okay so I have no idea why this
is here and why anything is I'm gonna
get back to my place
Oh mumphrey and I got a mannequin with
me
I got another chair apparently and a
shovel I'll put you right right there
whoops [ __ ] sorry
I meant to do that with a bit more grace
whoa okay someone likes to party
boobity boo okey-dokey then Herbert de
beber can you just behave there we go
you're gonna keep a watchful eye on that
damn neighbor of mine okay
whoa I can't believe how long that
[ __ ] took but I did it and I got this
whatever the hell this is I don't know
maybe I'm trying to rescue everybody
from being over there and when they come
back to my home they're gonna finally
become normal human again was that go
same floor yes I don't know what's on
the name floor [ __ ] by not good
was he up here Oh God oh okay
[Music]
I bet exuberant he [ __ ] he is I bet he
is
okay I don't know where I am that
goddamn thing is so goddamn loud talked
about them
don't worry is
he's nearby Oh aah
whoo this looks nice I'm gonna push this
big button okay I turned off the cameras
I think I shouldn't just jump down into
the rugged frickin frackin the frickin
other thing when I hide under my bed
until it's time to not hide under my bed
no don't sleep no don't sleep don't
sleep you [ __ ]
did you sleep thank you god damn it okay
well I didn't want to do that it just
did that by itself but I think I still
got everything that I needed from before
the only problem is he might have put
more security measures in place maybe he
didn't cuz he didn't catch me so maybe
that counts just gonna go in the
elevator yeah okay that was definitely a
new come on what the what the [ __ ] oh
come on oh [ __ ] god damn it why did
you go to sleep maybe uh
no no hey come on now hey Oh oops forget
get back out of there ah but I know
where the crowbar is now and with the
crowbar I could open the exit door maybe
why what did I do
oh come on just get on it get on it you
don't know where I am I am hidden way to
better than you can find no one will
ever know where I [ __ ] you God wha that
is such [ __ ] okay hey dickweed
I mean neighbor okay that's open I guess
really so it's just open okay well then
let me just get under here grab a little
bit of this all here oh oh [ __ ]
finally weird my crowbar go that's oh my
god damn crowbar did I not grab the
goddamn crowbar where the [ __ ] did the
crowbar go are you [ __ ] kidding me
with this oh why is it there [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] maybe a little bit [ __ ] you
oh really oh you think that's gonna stop
me how about no he didn't suspect a
thing and now I'm gonna use this hat to
bash my way in there
ah yes hooba-dooba hooba-dooba there's
still a lock on there so I got to find
something to get the lock off and I bet
that's on the second floor somehow and
that means that I got to build a
staircase straight up to the alcove on
the outside and then I'll be able to get
in there oh Jesus
okay then oh where did they go
well threw that away well that did that
well okay that's just not right that's
that's I I'm pretty sure that's probably
not possible
Oh God again with you this thing is a
menace oh so close
oh come on so close what what why why
okay so I've learned a few things about
this I had to restart the game again
because once again it was getting way
too overly complicated for me and also
the lawnmower is just death on the ears
it's horrifying so let me just who
should who should
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] that's
again ah [ __ ] goddamn it ha ha ha I'm
such an [ __ ] I knew I was in danger
why did I keep doing it okay so he's
downstairs now but this room is still
locked off so that's a problem but
there's got to be a key somewhere around
here I just won't be able to get up
there bye goddamnit
ah [ __ ] you I'm getting out here [ __ ]
once again it's goddamn night why the
only one out here the only one oh [ __ ]
you God [ __ ] a doc I'm assuming you
stone stairs oh boy
maybe I assumed wrong okay what's that
hmm hey that's the thing is this a
lockpick maybe yes I think it is but I
also think I'm bone I am boned
damn give this down yes yes yes yes yes
okay this is good are you being a dick
no no no no no okay I slept okay just in
time for that to happen but now I know
for certain that I have a lock pick on
me so the only thing I need to do is not
die how did I not see that before like
it could have been obvious I just didn't
look in that room besides all the color
from monitors bright shining lights got
the best of me and then Markie moon was
totally thwarted but not this time
because I have a lock of pick I have a
pick of lock would say what the hell hi
oh did you just body slam oh hey wait a
minute
uh what well that's the end are you
kidding me he just kills you no he
doesn't kill you he buries you alive I
think I reached the end but that's
something for you guys to experiment
with if you guys want to try that maybe
there's two bells they're hard to get
the one of them is hard to get once
pretty easy but if you get the Bell then
you get the shovel then you get the
other Bell then maybe it might work but
I have no idea but I'll leave that up to
you guys thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I'll see you in
the next video bye bye
[Music]